you should be gay hey you watching hello
you should be gay Oreos you're gay
what was that oh man I really want some
Oreos you know what we haven't done in a
while woke commercials and we haven't
done it I think because I'm just getting
too good at them I think that Mr Davey
is over there in the control room he
just knows that I'm too Adept at
guessing what product the woke
commercials are trying to sell the other
reason perhaps is that the corporations
are recognizing that when they go woke
their profits utterly collapse and their
customers turn on them and they sustain
boycotts for months at a time so that
might explain it too but in any case
we've discovered a few more what
commercials I will now bring to bear my
expertise which admittedly I'm only
batting 300 at best but 300 in baseball
is pretty good they're tough to figure
out I'm going to bring that
sophistication to Bear to these
commercials
the patriarchy instead I'm going to talk
about a dynasty that I actually look up
to
and all women
of the Amazons gay women women who fight
oh I'm not guessing what she's what
dynasty it is I'm gonna say it's like a
sports thing it's gonna okay it's a
sports thing it's gonna be like uh like
Nike I'm gonna but but I want points if
it's some other type of athletic word
company Dynasty with crazy dimes a
dynasty that makes Alexander Great look
like Alexander okay
okay can you oh you've got to be kidding
me Alexander the Great conquered almost
the entire Known World Brittany Greiner
the lady basketball player who was just
referenced on screen could not even
sneak a dime bag of pot into Russia oh
what a loose
I guess we have different perspectives
on History keep going the dynasty that's
been raining for the best 25 years since
the six
a basketball women's national team which
no one's ever watched not even once is
it Nike kid that I saw a swish on there
it's like me just feel like they can be
a part of whatever Dynasty man I'm good
the greatest Dynasty ever
yeah
oh man starting out
strong wow because they're getting a
little bit more predictable these
corporations and I thought what had to
be an athletic wear company what
athletic wear company is stupid enough
to endorse an unpopular sport that often
is anti-American and which has got to be
gotta be Nike right now go to
expressvpn.com Michael YT it is
extremely important to protect your
online privacy with the VPN choosing a
VPN that you trust
equally important I can say with full
confidence that expressvpn is the best
VPN on the market here is why number one
expressvpn doesn't log your online
activity they've even developed a
trusted server technology that makes it
impossible for their servers to store
any data at all
2 speed expressvpn does not slow down
your user experience you can even stream
HD videos with zero buffering number
three expressvpn is incredibly easy to
use just fire up the app and tap one
button to connect it's not just me
saying this Business Insider The Verge
many other Tech journals rate expressvpn
the number one VPN in the world protect
yourself with the VPN that I trust use
my link expressvpn.com Michael YT today
get three months free in a one year
package
expresvpn.com Michael YT letter y letter
T expressvpn.com Michael YT head on over
there today
my dad always told me that
I love my hair
okay so it could be like a shampoo thing
so excuse me sir could be like Dove or
product gamble is always the safest
Choice I'm afraid I can't let you attend
school today
even when it wasn't easy
we talked about this you can't wear
braids if you want to walk at graduation
has that ever happened
nope has that ever once happened at any
public school in America I'm talking
like back in Bull Connor days like
segregation now segregation forever
height of racial tensions in schools has
that ever once happened where some white
teacher walks up and says hey black girl
if you have hair you can't be here go
away that's just so Fantastical and
absurd and I just don't it's exactly as
believable as the rest of these things
so okay
um I'm still
leaning on it's
Dove or Procter Gamble that's kind of
the world I'm in right now keep going
even when no one else did
[Music]
my dad always told me that I should
fight for my hair
so I am
[Music]
Dove I'm gonna say
that it could be Procter Gamble
I want partial credit if it's if it's
one and not the other
dove oh what
oh man so the thing that tipped it
toward Dove at the end is dove often has
that kind of creamy logo you know that
creamy white so I thought okay if it has
to now Procter and Gamble's is pretty
close too they often have a kind of
white background but I thought it's got
to be I know Dove has done these World
commercials PNG does 40 of the what
commercials in the world but it was so
specific to hair why do I even need to
explain why I'm so good at this get
betting a thousand what
next one
[Music]
listen up babies
life's not fair
you get no say in the world you're born
into
you don't decide your name
you don't decide where you come from
you don't decide if you have a place to
call home
or if your whole family has to leave the
country
I only recognize half of these names I
assume they're all celebrities but you
don't decide how the world judges a
person like you
you don't decide how your Story begins
so it's
but some sports thing again so is it
[Music]
it's p.m no it's Nike again I shouldn't
get Nike again I just didn't think you'd
do well black power salute for that I
just didn't think that is that cheating
you can't do the same company twice in a
row your point being an academic
vernacular you cheated because I would
say it was like I guess it would be Nike
but I wish I could save that at a
thousand but let's say I get partial
credit that still puts me at what like
north of 700 that's nice man hmm oh
all those athletes on the list ain't got
nothing on me man I'm just I I float
like a butterfly sting like a bee you
know ah
just do it
just do it subscribe to the show we'll
see you next time just do it